[Music]
what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and we
have some really really big news for all
of you defenders fans out there we're
talking about the punisher daredevil
jessica jones luke cage iron fist and of
course the defender show as well there's
been a lot of speculation about these
shows and these characters recently as
far as how they exactly fit into the mcu
because during the hawkeye series
spoiler alert if you haven't seen it and
managed to avoid the spoiler kingpin
appeared and it was vincent d'onofrio
the same exact kingpin that we saw in
the netflix daredevil series now
dinofrio even came out and said that yes
it is the same exact kingpin that
appeared in the daredevil series
although some still question on whether
or not that's true but he is going to be
appearing in the echo disney plus series
that is going to be coming up later on
so hopefully that'll provide more
clarity however big news today
concerning everybody else fans will be
happy to know that all of these other
netflix marvel shows will be coming to
disney plus and or hulu next month it
was announced not too long ago that all
of these shows were going to be taken
off of netflix and fans were pretty
disappointed but also very excited
because it seemed like marvel studios
was actually going to do something with
these shows and now we know what they're
doing they're putting them on disney
plus in an announcement from marvel it
talks about the new shows coming this
month and of course we have a moon night
that is going to be premiering on march
30th and then it says new this month
march 16th and then it lists all of
these shows daredevil the punisher
jessica jones luke cage iron fist and
the defenders now there has been a
little bit of a debate on whether or not
these are going to actually show up on
disney plus or on hulu some of these are
kind of mature and a little bit more
hard hitting than the other disney plus
marvel shows and typically marvel and
disney will put their more mature
content on disney plus however according
to this statement piece it does seem
like they will be on disney plus we'll
have to wait and see on that but the
good news is is that all of the rights
to these shows has now fallen back to
marvel studios and disney their deal
with netflix is over this means much
like we saw in the hawkeye series marvel
studios in disney are free to use these
characters in the actual mcu and i know
a lot of other fans are really wanting
some of these characters like the
punisher to show up in the mcu so this
is a really good sign that they're
coming to disney plus now of course the
big question here is are they canon to
the mcu did they take place in the mcu
the entire time originally i would have
told you no absolutely not although it's
quite a mystery right now we saw matt
murdock in spiderman no way home and it
looks like he has actually been
daredevil for quite some time we saw how
easily he caught the brick before it hit
peter parker he smiles and makes the
joke i'm a really good lawyer which
really means i'm a really good superhero
too so it looks like he's been daredevil
for quite some time now and obviously
kingpin has been the kingpin for quite
some time in the mcu as well so these
characters and more characters that we
could see like the punisher and luke
cage have technically all been their
character for some time now in their own
series but does that transfer over to
the mcu and if so what exactly does this
mean was any part of the mcu or any
other characters affected by their
stories during their netflix shows these
are questions that we're going to have
to wait to find out unfortunately but
this is exciting news knowing the
possibility that these other heroes
could be appearing in the mcu at some
point in time kingpin and daredevil
opened up the door and now these other
shows are coming to disney plus these
are all really really good signs now of
course it could just be a pick and
choose situation where kevin feige felt
that kingpin was necessary for the
hawkeye series so they threw him in
there the same thing with daredevil it
was necessary for spider-man knowing
home there may not be any solid plans to
put these characters in other movies or
shows but if the moment fits it's good
to know that they are not against
putting them in the mcu so super super
exciting news today all of these shows
are going to be coming to disney plus
and or hulu march 16th and hopefully
we'll be seeing some of these other
characters in some disney plus shows or
in movies sometime soon in the mcu let
me know your thoughts about this in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest news for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof